how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
mcu and one division is now over most of
us by now have watched the finale and if
you haven't you need to get on that
because it's truly
awesome and not only that but now we're
moving forward into doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness they started
filming then it was put on hold due to
the pandemic but filming is going to
start again which means
leaks are going to start coming in fact
we already have some supposed leaks that
i'll be talking about in this video
along with an official synopsis that was
actually released
months ago but is now starting to line
up with what we've seen
in wanda vision and one very important
thing that the synopsis says
mentions something that agatha harkness
specifically says
in the one division finale and it's
extremely important because it has to do
with where we left off in one division
what's going to happen in doctor strange
and the future of the mcu
so in this video i'll talk about the
plot synopsis the leaks that line up
with the plot synopsis and what we can
expect from doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness from
the scarlet witch if you're new and you
love marvel be sure to subscribe so you
can stay up to date on all of the latest
mcu news
so like i said this plot synopsis came
out months ago so you may have heard it
already but it has different meaning now
that we've seen one division
but it reads as follows after the events
of avengers in-game
dr steven strange continues his research
on the time stone
but an old friend turned enemy seeks to
destroy
every sorcerer on earth messing with
strange's plan and also causing him to
unleash an unspeakable evil
so this synopsis is actually extremely
important when it comes to what is going
to happen in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
and even though it doesn't specifically
say wanda or the scarlet witch in it
it is definitely referring to her and
i'll explain how but first let's address
these three extremely important parts of
the synopsis
one of which ties directly into
something that agatha harkness said in
the one division finale in episode 9.
the first very important part that they
mention is the time stone doctor strange
is going to continue his research on the
time stone
now some people may think well the time
stone and all of the infinity stones are
destroyed it's gone and that is
technically true but that doesn't mean
that they're gone forever
if you recall thanos said that he simply
reduced the stones to atoms
where are the stones gone
reduced to atoms you used them two days
ago
i used the stones to destroy the stones
and then the russo brothers who directed
avengers infinity war and avengers
in-game said that
thanos technically didn't destroy them
he reduced them to atoms
implying that they could be reforged in
some way shape or form to make the
infinity stones again
and it sounds like that's a very
important thing that doctor strange is
actually going to need to do because if
you recall what he said in avengers
infinity war
his job as he said to tony stark was to
protect
the reality and as the ancient one
explained in avengers in game 2
professor hulk the infinity stones make
up
what we perceive as time she then says
if the infinity stone is gone without
their chief weapon against the forces of
darkness their reality will be
overrun so it's clear that they need the
time stone
in this reality they need it for several
reasons one is because it kind of is a
part of the universe but two
they need it to fight against the
darkness which is definitely going to
come
more on that and the third important
point but in the second important point
they mention a friend
turned enemy and of course we know who
this is this is
mordo in the post credit scene of the
first doctor strange we learned that
mordor thinks there are too many
sorcerers so when they say that an old
friend turned enemy seeks to destroy
every sorcerer on earth we absolutely
know who this is and of course it's been
confirmed that he is going to be
returning in this film and it sounds
like he's going to have some pretty
interesting interactions with wanda and
could be responsible for
her releasing unspeakable evil which is
the third point of this synopsis
it says that mordo will mess with doctor
strange's plan and also
cause him to unleash unspeakable evil
now kind of a spoiler warning for one of
vision episode 9 the finale if you
haven't seen it yet you might want to
click away now
not huge spoilers but during the fight
between agatha harkness and
wanda wanda is giving agatha the energy
of
chaos magic now of course that's not
really what was happening
wanda actually embraced her chaos magic
and agatha says
you have no idea what you've done and
then when they get back on the ground
agatha tells wanda or now the scarlet
witch
you have no idea what you've unleashed
you're going to need me
this falls right in line with the third
part of this synopsis where
it says that mordo is going to mess with
doctor strange's plan
and unleash unspeakable evil now there's
a lot that ties into unspeakable
evil with wanda her chaos magic and the
darkhold book which she now has which
was in the post-credits scene of one
division
and the directors of both one division
and the people who are working on doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
have already stated that is the tie-in
wanda studying the darkhold in her
astral form while simply casually
sipping tea on the outside in the real
world
just like doctor strange did when he was
sleeping but still studying
but let's tie this all together after we
go over this plot leak
which take with a grain of salt because
you never know but it seems pretty
legitimate and it starts off by saying
the second post-credit scene in one
division is a prelude to a scene from
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness and it takes place in
sokovia a lot of us were asking where
exactly is wanda
in this post-credit scene she's kind of
in the middle of nowhere in the
mountains
but it would make sense that she would
go home to sokovia but want to be
secluded
so we really don't have any reason to
believe that she wouldn't be in sokovia
it then goes on to say that wanda will
use the darkhold to resolve some of her
personal issues
now this could mean a whole different
number of things but the first thing
that comes to my mind when i hear this
and i think a lot of people's minds is
her kids the last time we left her she
was reading the dark cold
learning and then she heard her kids and
i can only assume that she's going to
want to try and track them down and this
is going to play a big part in
multiverse of madness
and then it says that mordo will pretend
to be wanda's friend
in order to have her as an ally now
wanda doesn't really know doctor strange
that well she's probably only met him
one time in tony stark's funeral in
avengers end game therefore she wouldn't
actually know if morta was
a good sorcerer or a bad sorcerer and he
could always trick her because he is a
talented sorcerer as well
and very experienced and since he's
trying to get rid of all of the
sorcerers he is definitely going to be
aware of
wanda especially after we've learned
that she is the scarlet witch
then says agatha could return as wanda's
counselor and this kind of makes sense
because
in the comics agatha is actually good
she actually helps
wanda learn and develop her powers now
of course in one division she's evil but
she did say that wanda was going to need
her help and wanda said if she does she
knows where to find her so it is always
possible that she goes back and does get
the help of agatha harkness
it says we will see a team up of
interdimensional villains in a perfect
cgi sequence never before seen in the
mcu
which makes perfect sense because if
this show is going to be about the
multiverse
and it is and we're going to be going
between dimensions and realities
we can probably expect some pretty good
stuff to happen but it says that there
won't be just
one villain doctor strange and wanda
will have to fight with threats
from several universes which have
collapsed
now given the title of the film
multiverse of madness this makes
absolute sense that they would fight
more than one villain
from more than one universe and it says
that the biggest person responsible for
the villains plot is
mordo who will trick wanda into evoking
up nightmare but ends up bringing
chaos to the multiverse by unleashing
interdimensional entities
and one of the main plot points is about
the villains trying to destroy wanda
because she is one of the most powerful
beings in existence
now nightmare was originally supposed to
be the main villain for the first doctor
strange film however they decided to go
with dormammu but they stated several
times that nightmare was indeed supposed
to be the villain of doctor strange 2.
now this was originally supposed to be
directed by scott derrickson and is now
going to be directed by sam raimi but as
far as we know
nothing has really changed unless sam
raimi came in and decided to completely
scrap whatever they had which i don't
think is going to happen
now based off of everything that we've
heard it's pretty clear that wanda is
going to be pretty responsible for
whatever is happening in the multiverse
of madness
she clearly unleashed something agatha
harkness made this pretty clear in the
one division finale
and she is actively studying the
darkhold which is dark
evil magic the book of the damned made
by the evil elder god c'thun
and it's definitely capable of releasing
very evil entities
which is what it sounds like is going to
happen now this obviously is going
to concern doctor strange and we
obviously know that wanda isn't bad
she's a good person who went through
extremely hard times
so wanda may accidentally unleash this
evil but she's going to help dr strange
try and defeat them and that seems like
what we can expect from doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness doctor
strange becomes aware of everything that
wanda just went through
becomes aware that she is the scarlet
witch she unleashes some unspeakable
evil and some entities the multiverse
kind of gets blown up into madness
and it's up to strange and wanda to fix
it but mordo is going to be trying to
stop them and it seems like that's what
we can expect from doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness
but like i said filming is going to
resume soon and we'll find out a lot
more so be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos
in the meantime let me know how you feel
about this in the comments down below
would this be something you would like
to see on screen
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof